the coronavirus 19 crisis that
we are experiencing needs a
strong and forceful response
from Europe and that is why today at the meeting of
leaders organized by the pes from the
group of socialists and democrats we
present a plan on which we have
worked a plan  which responds to the
need to act in the short term with
urgent measures but also in the medium and
long term in order to be able to prepare
for this situation, the first thing is to save
lives save human lives but
we also have to prepare ourselves for the effects
that this situation is going to have  With
regard to the economic and social crisis,
we must prevent the situation that
millions of
workers in Europe may experience. We must be
able to have a
coordinated response from the European Union
on how to respond
to this health crisis, and we are going to
work so that Europe  be active
working on an issue that is serious
and that we need from
European social democracy
and respond with urgent
measures with economic measures with social measures
and above all with the principle of
solidarity
Europe has been built on the basis of
solidarity and today more than ever we
need a united Europe that
can respond to this situation